-You and I had
the most wonderful trip,
because we met in Amsterdam.
We worked for a theater
called Boom Chicago.
And Boom Chicago had its
25th anniversary this summer.
-It did.
-Which was great because I think
only a 25th anniversary
would our spouses allow us
to go back to Amsterdam.
-Yeah.
-And there's a bunch of us here.
Colton Dunn,
there's my brother Josh,
Jill Benjamin, Josie O'Reilly,
Liz Cackowski.
-Liz Cackowski, good group.
-And how did you --
We were there for three days
back in Amsterdam,
where we lived in our 20s.
-Yeah, and it's very different
living in Amsterdam
when your in your mid-20s
than when you're early 40s.
-Yeah.
-It's bad when you're early 40s,
because your body --
I don't know
if you know this, Seth.
Your body changes
as you get older.
-Yeah.
-I don't know if you knew that.
-I found it out, and, you know,
when you're in your 20s,
you can drink, oh, 20 beers.
-Yeah.
-I did that with you
a couple months ago.
-Yeah, 'cause you definitely --
You still have the head
of a 20-year-old, my friend.
-Yeah, I do.
Yeah, I do.
Spiritually, I'm 20.
-Yeah.
-Physically, I'm --
-Your spirit animal
is you at 20.
[ Laughter ]
-It is.
And my physical animal is...
Remember Buddy Ebsen?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
From "The Beverly Hillbillies"?
-Yeah, that's --
that's who it is.
-Well I remember
you and Liz Cackowski,
who's a fantastic
comedian, writer,
you guys flew out together,
and the pictures on the flight
to Amsterdam, where you guys,
like, yeah, toast.
-Yeah.
-You're so happy.
And then tell us
about the flight home.
-The flight home,
I don't remember it,
but I remember turning to her
dramatically in the lounge
and going, "Liz,
I need to get on that plane."
Sounded like Harrison Ford in
"Air Force One,"
but the opposite.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. And she was like,
"All right, fine.
Don't worry about it."
-Now, it should be noted
that this is an early flight
leaving Amsterdam.
And how much had you slept?
-0.0 hours.
-Okay, gotcha. Yeah.
-I laid in a park.
-Yeah, you fell asleep in a park
for a second.
-Yeah, but I put my hat out.
I got a couple bucks.
[ Laughter ]
Bought a nice broodje
at the airport.
-Dutch for sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Yeah, it was --
But then, I woke up seven hours
in, I felt great.
-Yeah.
-And then for two weeks,
I had depression.
-Uh-huh.
-And then I felt great.
-Oh, well, that's good.
-Yes.
-Well, it was a great trip,
and it was worth
two weeks of depression.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No doubt.
-Your wife and my wife
both very nice.
I have two kids.
You've got three now.
-Three kids. Yeah.
-So, now I know
Halloween's coming up.
Are you guys
enthusiastic about it?
-They are.
The kids are.
We're doing a "Star Wars" theme.
-Oh, that's great.
-Yeah it's great.
Rey, then my wife is Leia,
then the middle kid is Yoda,
and then
the youngest is Chewbacca.
Han Solo, obviously.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-But maybe Han
from "The Force Awakens."
The kind of slower...
"Huh, huh. Huh."
He always looked surprised --
"Hunh! Hunh!"
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah.
-I'm glad you've gotten
a lot of your Harrison Ford
impression in tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I guess you can
open with your closer. Yay!
But, no, I'm not gonna have
any more kids.
I had a medical procedure.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-Yep.
I found a guy on Craigslist.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
He just -- He came over and just
kicked me in the nuts a bunch.
-Uh-huh.
-And, uh --
-But you did actually have --
-I did have the vasectomy.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah, which --
-Was everybody in the family
in agreement?
Was Erica behind the idea?
-It was Erica's idea.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And I jumped on board.
[ Laughter ]
It was kind of fine
for the first, you know --
Like three days, I was like,
"This is not a big deal."
-This is after the fact?
-This is after the fact.
And then the fact...
-Okay.
-...was that -- I don't know
how to say this.
My -- Well, my --
It turned purple.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, I don't mean like,
"Oh, it was kind of purple."
I mean, it was -- You know
Grimace from McDonald's?
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
If he had one,
it would look indistinguishable.
[ Laughter ]
So, I am the new face
of McDonald's.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-You made --
You made lemonade, my friend.
-Purple lemonade.
-Yeah, it really hurt, and
it was real scary for a minute.
But I'm fine now.
-Gotcha. You're fine now.
Back to like, 60% purple,
which is normal.
That's normal for me.
-Oh, that was where you were at.
That was your starting point.
-Yeah.
-My God, you have so many great
things going on right now.
-Got a vasectomy.
-You got a vasectomy.
-I'm gonna be old Han Solo.
[ Laughter ]
-Buddy, it is always just such
a pleasure to have you here.
Congrats again on the movie.
It's really amazing.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's Ike Barinholtz,
everybody.
I'm his friend.
"The Oath" is in theaters now.